Daniel: And now welcome aswin how are you
doing?
Aswin: Hi, Daniel.
I'm good.
Daniel: Hanging out, looking forward.
Aswin: Can you hear me properly?
Daniel: Yeah, sounds good.
And yes, looking forward to your workshop
on sophisticated inference in pymdp.
So it can be up to 90 minutes or it's
totally okay if it's less and we can take
a short break, but please take it away
and just let me know however I can help.
Aswin: Great.
Thank you so much.
Maybe I'll share my screen and start.
So, regarding the structure of what we
are doing here, I'm assuming that people
who see this later might want to try it
hands on along with the tutorial or
something.
So that's the structure I kept in mind.
And so I'll go slow.
Please bear with me.
So welcome all of you to this session on
sophisticated inference in pymdp.
So here we are going to attempt to model
some sophisticated inference simulations,
especially the one in the original paper
using the pymdp module and how it is not
part of pymdp right now.
But we are on the process of adding
sophisticated inference to the pymtp
module.
And I'm going to mainly talk about the
code that I have developed to kind of add
that functionality.
Right.
So I'm Ashwin Paul.
I am finally a PhD candidate at Monash
University.
And mostly I work with active inference
models and try to understand how to use
them as an explainable model to basically
understand emergence of intelligent
behavior.
Right, so let's dive into the material
right away.
So to give an intro of free energy
principle, I'm sure all of you right now
have an understanding of what it is.
But the central idea is that an agent is
always trying to minimize the entropy of
its observations, right?
So if an observation is having really low
probability in your mind and that happens,
, then you are probably surprised and
vice versa, right?
And the entropy here is defined as the
information theoretic entropy, where if
you have a low probability, then
automatically this is a high surprise or
a high entropic observation.
And as we all know, active inference also
gives us a methodology to define what we
call an agent environment loop.
And this lets us define what is the agent
that we are looking at and what is the
behavior of the agent given the
environment around it and so on.
Right?
So you're also familiar with the idea of
Marco Blanket.
And this is important because we always
have to remember, I mean, have to
remember the difference between the
generative process and the generative
model, which is quite a famous point of
confusion in active inference literature
and for the people who try to understand
it in the beginning.
Right?
So the central question is that how does
an agent minimize entropy?
Because how does an agent know which
observation is low or high
probabilistic?
Right?
So that is by maintaining a generative
model.
And the generative model will tell you
which is a high probabilistic observation
and which is a low probabilistic
observation.
So the idea is that all the agent has
access to is an observation that is
coming from a generative process which
the agent cannot directly observe.
And an intelligent agent will try to
build up a generative model in its mind,
which is a model of the hidden states and
the observation it has access to.
And it can hope to kind of compute
probabilities using this generative model,
, right?
But there is a problem that in general it
is an intractable problem to kind of
marginalize the probability of
observations from the generative model.
And that is why we have to define an
upper bound on the surprise that the
agent is trying to minimize.
And there comes the idea of free energy,
right?
So this upper bound the agent is
supposedly minimizing is the free energy.
.
And that's why it is the free energy
principle.
And here we have a new term called
capital QS, which can be interpreted as
the belief that the agent is maintaining
about the hidden state in its generative
model.
And this quantity is the free energy.
And traditionally we see this variational
free energy being interpreted as in
mostly the machine learning way where it
is a balance between complexity and
accuracy of the model.
So when minimizing the free energy, the
agent is trying to come up with a single
model but at the same time an accurate
model because here it's a minus sign with
accuracy, right?
It can also be interpreted in the physics
way where the agent is always trying to
minimize the energy of the model but at
the same time maximizing the entropy of
the model which goes in conjunction with
the maximum entropy principle and so on
from the classic literature.
So, given that this idea of a generative
model is so important in a software point
of view, that's the first thing that you
might want to do, right, to define a
generative model for the agent which is
informed or not informed depending upon
the experiment that you're trying to
model.
So in classical active inference, usually
decision making is defined in terms of
policies.
So, for example, if you are an agent in
this environment so in the Mario game,
Mario is the agent and everything else is
the environment.
And Mario has three available actions run,
, jump or stay in this environment.
And the classic definition of policy is
that it is a sequence of actions in time.
.
So if you have a time horizon of capital
T, then a policy is nothing but a series
of actions you might take.
So run, run, jump and so on in time.
So this is the SuperScript is the action.
.
So here it is jump, run and so on.
And the subscript is the time.
And then what you can have is a policy
space, which is a collection of many such
policies, small pi.
And what you essentially do to take
decisions in active inference is compute,
not optimize.
Compute the expected free energy of every
policy in your policy space.
And basically, that can be interpreted as
a balance between risk and ambiguity.
So when you compute this expected free
energy, what you're trying to do is
minimizing the risk.
That is, how different is your belief
about the observation from your prior
preferences?
Capital C.
So this is also part of the generative
model when you're trying to model control
and at the same time you are trying to
minimize the ambiguity when you are
choosing a policy that has the minimum
expected free energy, right?
But this formulation has a problem that a
policy space quickly becomes intractable,
that there can be an enormous number of
small pies or policies in your policy
space and sitting and computing the
expected free energy for all such
policies even for a small time horizon,
is not possible.
But this is the classical structure that
has been implemented in Pymdp nonetheless,
, where we have different modules in
Pymdp that is meant to be implementing
different aspects of behavior.
So for example, for inference or
perception we have belief propagation,
fixed point iteration, marginal message
passing and all that implemented in the
inference module.
In the control module we have different
methods to evaluate expected free energy
for policies, one depending upon the
expected utility, the other one depending
upon the classic method that I just
explained.
Then we have module for learning.
So we learn the parameters in the form DP
like capital A, capital B, so likelihood
transition dynamics and so on.
And then we have algorithms for
implementing all this in the algorithms
module.
And then the most powerful thing in Pymdp
right now is the agent class where it is
easy for you to kind of define the agent
environment loop and we are trying to
build up.
So today I'm going to talk about an agent
class that implements sophisticated
inference rather than the classical
active inference that we just saw.
So, as I mentioned, how many valid
policies can be defined, say for a time
horizon of 15 in classical active
inference?
Right?
So the first policy of course, is a
series of first action that is jumped,
then you can have the last action changed
and you already can see that there can be
n number of combinations.
And for this simple case, the policy
space is as big as ten to the power 13.
And in a stochastic problem setting there
is no way to kind of come up with a small
subset of this policy space so that you
can tackle this problem of computational
complexity.
And yeah, as I mentioned, in a stochastic
problem setting it is an intractable size
policy space.
There comes the idea of sophisticated
inference where we are thinking about
taking decisions in a different way,
right?
So rather than thinking about sequence of
actions in time, we can directly think of
what to do when we see something
depending upon our beliefs about the
current state and beliefs about the
future, right?
So if I see myself in a current situation,
, what should I do?
And that's more like a straightforward
thinking of how to take actions.
And here the expected free energy.
The structure of the expected free energy
is the same but we are not evaluating
expected free energy of policies, but
expected free energy of observation
action combinations.
So if I see something and if I do this,
what's the expected free energy?
And that's what I'm trying to minimize.
That's what I'm trying to optimize in
this setting, right?
So here again, we have the risk term
where we are trying to minimize the
deviation between the belief and the
prior preferences.
We also have the ambiguity term and this
together makes up the expected free
energy of this time point at time T.
But we also have an expectation about
what's the expected free energy in the
next time step.
And to evaluate the expected free energy
of next time step, you will have to again
compute this equation with OT plus two.
And for that you will have to again
compute this equation with OT plus three
and so on.
And this automatically becomes a tree
search because of the recursive way this
equation is defined and it comes with its
own problems, but there are clever ways
to get around them and we are going to
discuss that in the code today.
So, given the structure of sophisticated
inference here, as I mentioned, the
research replace the policy space that we
saw for the traditional active inference
we are used to.
So in this workshop, what I am focusing
on is how to kind of define a generative
model and given an environment.
So for example, this is the grid that is
simulated in the original paper and we
are going to talk about how to build up a
generative model for this grid that can
be used in the sophisticated inference in
the PMDP module.
So basically, what I'm trying to talk
about is that the environment will have a
step function that takes an action from
the agent in Pymdp, and the agent will
get an observation out of that action and
we'll talk about this particular function,
, agent step and agent steps.
Step will take up an observation and try
to come up with an action for the next
time.
Step right.
And this creates a loop and cleverly
designing this loop will let you see
emergence of purposeful behavior in the
sophisticated inference setting.
So for example, in this particular grid
with sufficient planning horizon, you
will be able to see that the agent is
capable of navigating in this grid and so
on.
So this is the example that I'm going to
focus on in this talk today.
Excuse me, I want to right away jump in
to the code.
So we have the Pymdp home, which I'm
hoping you are familiar with.
So we have this GitHub repository where
we have the pymdp module and inside pymdp
module we have several parts for it.
So here we have the agent in the original
Pymdp module that implements the so
called classical active inference.
We have several environments and we have
help of functions like learning inference,
, maths and so on.
So this is the module of Pimedp.
But in the parent folder we also have
examples where there is tutorials about
how to use the agent class, how to kind
of deal with the environments and so on.
So if you look at the pull requests so we
are right now trying to merge
sophisticated inference into the original
Pymdp module.
And today I'm going to talk about the
code in this pull request.
So if you want to try this hands on, you
might want to go to this page where this
pull request is there and it has the same
structure of Pymdp.
It's basically designed using Pymdp.
And here what we have additionally is an
agent si which is a sophisticated
inference agent which does everything and
also planning and decision making in the
sophisticated inference way.
And in the parent folder there is also an
example folder for sophisticated
inference demo.
And what I am going to do today is to
walk you through this tutorial of
sophisticated inference.
And on the way, I'm going to discuss and
at points where I reference the helper
codes, I'm going to go to that code and
try to explain what's actually happening
and how we complete that agent
environment loop where we can see that
purposeful behavior.
Right?
Yeah.
So that's the Pymdp home.
Then I also talked about the pull request.
.
So let's right away go into the jupyter
notebook.
So this is my local copy of this
repository, so it's easier for me to run
it and show it in my personal computer.
So this is the parent folder with Pymdp
and examples and inside examples I have a
demo folder for sophisticated inference
and this is the notebook I'm talking
about.
Right?
So here in this example, what we are
trying to do is deal with this particular
grid world task from the original
sophisticated inference paper and make
this agent or enable this agent to
navigate to this red dot, which is
supposedly the goal state in this
particular task given a prior preference
like this, right?
So this prior preference is quite
informative in the sense that we right
away can see that this is the most
preferred state, the white color and the
surrounding states are kind of less
preferred, but more preferred than the
faraway ones.
Right?
So this is the grid world task that we
are trying to use.
So the first cell is importing all the
necessary libraries and some useful
libraries like NumPy and Matplotlib.
And the most important one is Pymdp.
So I'm actually now calling the local
copy of my Pymdp with the sophisticated
inference implementation, not the
original one, which is not merged yet.
And the first thing I want to talk about
is the environment itself, right?
So the environment step part where if I
get some action, how does the environment
work?
And for that, inside this folder I have a
file which is Grid environment Si PY and
this is basically an environment class.
So don't worry about how this environment
is actually implemented.
The only thing to worry about is this
function that we are going to use which
is environment step.
So this function will take an action into
it and depending upon the current state
of the environment, it will calculate
what is the most probable next state
given this action from the agent.
So that's the idea.
And then it will also calculate a reward
of some negligible negative value if it
is not the Gold State, and if it is the
Gold State, it will give a reward of ten.
.
And that's how the environment is.
Designed and it will update the current
state to the new state.
And basically what it will return is a
new state, depending upon your action,
the reward for that action and whether it
is an end of the episode and so on.
So this implementation is the standard
OpenAI environment implementation and
this is the environment step function,
right?
So in this grid, for example, if I am
right now in this state and if I take an
action up, so I have four available
actions north, South, east and west.
So if I go on north, then the environment
step will make sure that I am in the
state that is above the state.
And if I go east or west, then I'll stay
here.
Or south.
I'll stay here.
So that's the idea.
And there is an episode length limit that
is eight here, that means that I am
restricting the length of every episode
to be eight, which is the ideal length of
reaching this goal state just to avoid
confusion.
So in this environment, after eight
actions, the environment will terminate.
And if you have to kind of reach this
goal state in the optimal time point so
that's the idea how the environment is
implemented.
Okay, I hope that is clear.
And there are many helpful functions in
this environment, like rendering the
environment, rendering a prior preference
matrix in this environment.
So if you design a prior preference, this
environment can show that in a pictorial
way how your prior preference is that you
will see in the notebook below.
So now it's time that we define a
generative model for the sophisticated
inference agent, right?
Before that, let's define the structure
of the generative model that we want the
agent to have in its mind, which is
tailor made for this particular
environment, right?
So here in this particular grid world
task, we have 25 valid states starting
from this state.
All this black states in this path are
valid states.
So there are 25 valid states.
Then there are four available actions for
the agent, north, Southeast and west.
So this is part of our generative model.
This is also in alignment with the
reality of the grid.
But this is about what the agent has in
its mind, right?
And then the observation is just the
state space.
The problem is fully observable, so there
is no ambiguity there.
Then we define basically the number of
states.
states, which is a list of your state
space, number of factors, which is now
one because you only have one hidden
state factor here.
Then number of controls, which is going
to be four.
That's four available actions and your
observation space like that.
So this is the structure of your
generative model.
And let's look at the structure of the
parameters now inside a POMDP.
So the first one is the likelihood
function which is often denoted by
capital A.
And here it is a function of how many
observational modalities I have and how
many state modalities I have.
Right?
If I run this cell, yeah, I have to run
the parent cell to make sure everything
works.
So I have rendered the environment the
structure of the generative model.
And here I have the capital A matrix
which has a structure 25 25.
That means that I have 25 states and 25
observations.
And here, because it's fully observable,
I am initializing it as an identity
matrix of size 25.
So that's my likelihood matrix that I'm
initializing for this particular grid
world task.
Then the second element is the transition
matrix.
So please note that I'm using all the
existing Pymdp functionalities to define
a random A matrix and then using an
identity matrix on top of that.
So, yeah, I'm not doing anything new.
Here it is the existing Pymdp
functionality.
Then what I can do now is define the B
matrix, which is also called transition
matrix.
So the transition matrix encodes
transitions like where I'm going to end
up in the future if I start from a
particular state and take an action.
So that's the idea where it depends upon
the number of states, which is the hidden
state modality and number of controls.
So it has the structure of state action
state where if I take an action from a
particular state where I'm going to end
up.
So that is also a future state, right.
So I'm going to initialize it as the true
environment state.
So now this is part of the environment
that I've built.
It will give out the B matrix.
It might be worth it to look at the
structure of this B matrix.
So here we have 25, 25 four.
So that means that if I take an action
from a particular state where I'm going
to enter and we have the true transition
dynamics for this particular grid by
design.
So there is a function called get true B
and that will give us the true b of the
system which the agent can use.
Okay?
So ideally we would want the agent to
learn this, but for the purpose of this
demo we are assuming that the agent
already knows the structure.
And then comes the prior preference,
which is interesting here in the sense
that it is defined as how closer you are
to the gold state.
So if you are at the gold state, then
clearly that is the most sought out state.
.
You prefer that the most.
And how do you prefer the neighboring
states, right?
So that is dependent upon the square root
of the distance or basically the distance
from that particular gold state.
So you define a grid which is eight cross
eight, the same size as this particular
grid world task.
And then we have a method to kind of add
values which is the preference you have
for every state.
And if you render the particular C matrix
you can see the structure which is the
same where this gold state is more
preferred and the surrounding states less
preferred and so on.
So now we have the C matrix also defined
in the classic PMDP way.
And then I initialize that C matrix as
the C matrix we evaluated in the previous
cell which is small C, this particular C
matrix.
Okay?
And then lastly, for the generative model
we have capital D which is your prior
overhead and states.
And for that I'm using a uniform object
array.
So that means that I don't have a prior
of where I am starting.
So let me run the pending cells.
So here the D matrix is a uniform
distribution over hidden states.
I don't know where I'm going to start the
simulations and so on.
So this is the basic structure of the
generative model.
And then we have the agent class which I
want to discuss separately, like the
environment, right?
So given these environment parameters,
how would you expect the agent class to
work?
So where is the agent class?
Inside this folder structure?
Inside the Pymdp module folder we have an
agent Si PY which is basically a class
again and similar to the environment
class here.
Also we have a step function where this
will take an observation to the function
and also a flag whether or not to learn
the environment, which is optional.
So if you disable it, it won't learn the
generative model.
If you enable it, it will update the
parameters of the generative model.
And what basically it does is it will
return an action which is to be taken at
this point of time and the environment
can basically use that action, right?
So in this file we have the agent class
which I will explain in detail.
So I am basically importing that agent
class in this cell and then we are going
to try and reproduce this behavioral
result from the original sophisticated
inference paper.
Okay?
And for that.
So what we expect is that given this
prior preference structure, there are
local maximas in this prior preference
structure.
So if you start from this particular
point, if you do not plan deep enough,
what you will end up is in one of these
local maximas where you don't see that
there is a highly preferred observation,
say four steps down the line.
So if you are in this particular state,
what you will see is this local maxima
and you will go and sit there because the
neighboring states are less preferred and
this state which is more preferred is not
accessible because of the wall or the
wall structure.
So you have to take a turn and pass
through less preferred states and you
need deep planning in order to enable the
agent to do that.
The agent should be able to kind of
simulate four time steps ahead in time to
see that there is this highly rewarding
observation coming to kind of do that
actions.
So that's the point that we are trying to
see in this particular demo.
So for a low planning depth it will
basically get stuck in one of the local
maximas but with sufficient planning
depth it will navigate to the gold state.
.
So that's what we are trying to see,
right?
So we have different planning horizons
and what we are basically doing is give
the agent a generative model which we
right now defined the A matrix, B matrix,
C matrix B matrix.
Then we have the planning horizon of
capital N.
So here I am, iterating over planning
depth.
So N will be one, three and four for the
loop.
Then we have action precision, which is
often denoted by alpha in active
inference literature.
So that determines which action is to be
taken.
So a highly precise action precision
means that it will stick to the action
with the lowest expected free energy.
But a lower action precision is kind of
probabilistic where it will also consider
other actions.
Then we have a planning precision which
is part of the planning function we'll
discuss, which is often denoted in the
literature as gamma.
Then we also have a search threshold
which is extremely important for
sophisticated inference because as we saw,
, sophisticated inference is a tree
search and tree search is bad in the
sense that it can have a lot of
computations.
But you have to define a threshold to
kind of ignore many possibilities to make
it work.
And that's the idea that we will also
discuss.
So just a preview before we go to the
agent class.
What we are trying to do is in a loop we
are going to call the agent step and
environment step in series.
So the agent will see an observation, it
will take an action, that action will go
into the environment, the environment
will give it back new observations and
this loop continues.
And we want to see over time how this
loop evolves into a purposeful behavior
and if the agent at all is capable for
that.
So before I reveal the results, let's
discuss the agent class.
So in order to give an action, when an
observation is given, the agent should
have the planning and so on, right?
So here is the agent, the sophisticated
inference agent, where we are actually
using the existing Pymdp agent for some
functionalities.
So in Pymdp we already have really well
written functions for perception and
learning.
So the only thing we want to kind of
replace is how the agent is doing
planning and how the agent is taking
decisions over policies, right?
So here we are using that parent agent
class.
So from Pymdp agent we are importing that
agent class which is sitting next to the
Si agent that we are discussing now.
And basically we are taking in the
generative model structure from the main
program for this class to work which is C
and D and all the precisions and
threshold parameter I mentioned, then it
is kind of normalizing the prior
preference that we mentioned in the main
program.
So here if I look at how C is, the
structure of C is defined in terms of
numbers and the prior preference is often
interpreted or it should be a
probabilistic distribution for the
computations to work, right?
So we are going to normalize it as a
probabilistic distribution rather than
having numbers that don't add up to one.
So that's what's happening here.
We are using Softmax to do that.
Then what we are doing is we are
initializing the existing PMDP agent with
these generative model parameters and
what we are intending to do is write a
planning function for a given planning
horizon and a given threshold for trees.
Okay, so there are three functions in
this agent class.
One is a helper function for planning
which we will discuss now.
Then there is a planning function itself
which is going to do planning using tree
search.
And then because it is a recursive tree
search, we are going to need an
additional function that implements that
recursive evaluation where we are going
to call this function called forward
search inside the function itself.
So we are calling this function inside
this function.
So that is to calculate expected free
energy for the next step and it will call
it again for the next step till our
planning horizon.
So that's the idea of recursive looping
and finally it will return the expected
free energy for all actions given an
observations and then we just implement
the step function where it is written
sequentially what to do given an
observation.
So going back to the demo here we have
this first idea where you get an
observation and it gives out an action.
So let's go to the agent step function
and imagine what happens.
So if it is time t equal to zero or in
the beginning of the experiment, what it
is ideally.
Supposed to do in the first place is
infer that state using its observation.
So what we are giving it is an
observation and using the modules for
inference, it's going to come up with a
belief QS, which is a belief about states.
.
Okay, so self dot QS is the belief inside
the agent and once it has a belief about
where it is right now, it can implement
plan research which is do planning for
this particular belief of hidden state
right now.
And once it has done planning, it can
take decision using the sample action
function in Pymdp and basically return
that action.
And for every other time steps, the
sequence remains the same.
But it is also learning about the
structure if you enable learning in your
agent class.
So that's the step function.
But in order to do planning, what it does
is it kind of reorganizes the generative
model structure for any number of hidden
state modalities and any number of
observation modalities.
So to discuss how melting works, I would
like to talk about the new A matrices and
B matrices it evaluates for implementing
that planning and let's understand that.
So let's go back to the original hidden
state factors.
So here we only have one hidden state
factor.
So that's why it is B zero, right?
And B one does not exist because we only
have one hidden state factor.
But imagine that if I have two hidden
state factors with the same size maybe.
So here it could be a location and maybe
something else inside the agent's mind.
And we should also have controls for
these two hidden state factors.
Just like so there should be control for
every hidden state factor if you're
familiar with active inference idea and
then maybe the observation space is also
directly observing these two hidden state
factors.
Okay, so this is a new Generative Model
structure with multiple hidden states and
multiple observation modalities.
And right away you can see that the
dimensionalities of your parameters
change.
You have 25 observations coming from 25
times 25 hidden states.
And if you look at the structure of the
first observation modality, it's the same.
.
But what we want is a new matrix where it'
's going to be 25 with not two hidden
states but just one hidden state.
It's only a reorganization of the
generative model, but computations
essentially remains the same.
So that's what this helper function is
trying to do, which will make things
easier for us when we have multiple
hidden state modalities.
So if you have multiple hidden state
modalities, we are going to compute how
many total states you have, which is the
multiplication of number of hidden states
in each modality.
Okay?
So if you have 25 hidden states in one
modality and 25 hidden states in the
other modality, you're going to have 625
total number of states.
And if you have four actions each in each
modalities, then you have total of 16
actions which is nothing but the
combination of these four actions each in
the modalities.
So you're going to have four times 416
actions if you have two modalities.
And it's basically going to build a
generative model that has the same model
parameters but just with a different
dimension structure so that it's easier
for us to calculate the expected.
So now we have a new A and new B and a
new belief which is nothing but tensor
products of existing parameters and
beliefs.
It's nothing but a new big matrix and
nothing else.
Okay?
It's not a change, it's just a
transformation of structure.
And given this A, B and Q, we are going
to predict what's going to happen in the
future and evaluate the expected free
energies for them.
So in order to do planning, so that's the
second function.
What we are going to do is first call the
first function which will do the melting
for us and set up the generative model in
good dimensions, easy to compute.
Then we have the expected free energy
itself for all the actions and then we
have the probability that depends upon
this expected free energy for these
actions.
So why is it just the actions and not the
observations?
Because here we are going to evaluate
expected free energy of actions for the
given observations, right?
So let me go back to the slides and
discuss this pictorially to make things
easier.
So here we have the grid and we have the
prior footprints.
And what we are trying to implement is
that if you observe some observation at
time T, then you're going to consider the
consequences of your actions given that
observation, because you can predict what'
's going to happen.
Because in your generative model you have
the transition dynamics that will tell
you, given this state, if I take this
action, where I'm going to end up,
right?
So that's basically predicting what's
going to happen in the future and you're
right now considering the consequence of
available actions in your arsenal.
And then if you take an action, then you
can predict what's going to happen in the
next time step as a new observation,
right?
So you have a probability distribution
that tells you that say this observation
is the most likely and the other
observations are not really likely.
Then what you will do is you do this
again, you consider the consequence of
doing your actions from that particular
observation and this goes on in your
planning depth, right?
So this can be thought of as maybe you
want to go to the gym.
Then you are going to consider all the
consequences.
What will happen if I wear my shoes, if I
don't wear my shoes, if I go in my car,
if I don't go in my car, then you realize
that, okay, I have to wear my shoes.
Then you consider the consequence that I'
'm now ready to go to the gym and me
going to the gym will end up me being in
the gym.
So that's the idea.
You consider the consequence of where you
are right now and you can go as much as
you want, right.
You can predict.
So in a game of chess, you might be in a
particular state.
You consider your consequences, you see
the future, you consider consequences
from that future, and you can go as deep
as you want depending upon your
computational abilities.
Right.
So that's what you're trying to implement
in this agent class where we are
considering consequences?
Yeah.
So for every modality we are going to
consider the expected free energy for
actions.
And this will basically call the next
function, which is forward search.
So forward search is implementing the
thing that I just mentioned, considering
consequences.
And in forward search, what you are
basically doing is for every action.
So in line 149, I have a loop that goes
over every action.
Then I'm going to consider the posterior
or the consequences of all those actions.
.
I use my transition probabilities to
evaluate that consequences.
Then I'm going to predict the
observations, because my prior
preferences are defined in terms of
observations.
I'm going to predict my observations and
then evaluate the expected free energy,
which is the sum of risk and ambiguity.
Okay?
I hope that makes sense.
Like here, you have considered the
consequence, which is consequence of
future, which is post or posterior.
And you're basically evaluating how good
that posterior is depending upon your
expected free energy.
And that becomes the expected free energy
for that particular action.
And you do this for all the actions.
Okay.
And why this is powerful?
It is because you can go as deep as you
want.
So here in the next step, you go to this
loop where you will check if I am
crossing my deep planning or the depth of
planning.
And then you are doing basically the same.
.
Given that posterior, what is the
consequence of the actions of that
particular posterior.
So here for considering that we are again
calling the parent function.
So the same function, forward search, to
consider consequences of those
combinations and it will basically come
back and add up to your expected free
energy.
So what happens over this sequence is
that you consider some or all future
consequences and then all that values
will trickle up your tree.
And that sum of the expected free energy
will tell you which action is good or
which action is bad, which you can take
to kind of see your preferred
observations.
So that's the idea of implementing tree
search.
And I will also talk about the importance
of this threshold here, which makes this
algorithm possible.
So without this threshold, this algorithm
will not work.
I will explicitly talk about why that is
the case.
And then once you evaluate the expected
free energy for all available actions,
given the present state, you can
basically compute what you call the
action distribution.
That is how probable is my action or how
I should take my action.
And we also have this action precision
parameter alpha.
So if alpha is very high then it
basically is a highly skewed distribution
where you will always choose the action
that minimizes expected free energy.
If alpha is really low then it's going to
be a more sparse or spread out
distribution.
And then you can use this action
distribution to sample actions in the
agent environment loop.
We just finished doing planning and
computing that action distribution.
Then using that action distribution, you
can sample an action from your policy
space.
So let's look at the policy space in this
generative model.
So I'm switching back to the original
generative model with one hidden state
factor and let's do planning and maybe
initialize this agent.
I just want to initialize this agent to
see the policy space, not run the loop.
So I initialize this agent, say for
planning depth of one.
And if I look at agent policies, I can
see that I have basically four available
actions which is north, south, east and
west.
And if I have an action distribution, it
will tell me how probable is to take that
action.
So if I look at agent UPI, okay, so this
is not defined because I have not done
planning, but I can do planning and then
it will be defined.
Yeah, so I implemented planning with
research and then now I have an action
distribution.
So for this particular scenario, I am
going to take my third action the most
which is zero point 99.
Basically that's the probability which is
north, south and east in this particular
case.
I just wanted to kind of familiarize you
with the matrices, but we are now going
to see the agent environment loop in
action.
Now you can sample an action from the
sample action function and then implement
learning which is using the standard
Pymdp way where I will update my
transition dynamics and likelihood
dynamics depending upon what I see and
what's my belief and so on.
So my emphasis is on the decision making
part.
So once you sample an action, then that
action basically goes back to the
environment.
Okay, so now let us implement this for a
planning depth of one and see how the
agent behaves.
So here if it is a planning depth of one,
then that means that the agent is only
considering the consequence of one time
step ahead, just seeing the immediate
future for doing planning, right?
So I'm giving the planning depth of one.
I'm resetting the environment where the
agent is going to start from that initial
start state, and in the loop, it's going
to get that observation, take that action,
, give back an action, and we will look
at the action probabilities.
And also we will give that action back to
the environment, get back the observation,
, and this loop continues till the
episode is terminated.
And I have set the episode length to be
eight, just to see the outcome of eight
action.
So when we run this loop, these matrices
are nothing but the action distributions
of how likely each action is to be taken.
.
And this is where the agent end up in the
last time step.
Okay?
So let's maybe kind of also enable this
environment render that will show us
where the agent is at every time step.
So initially the agent was at this
location and we have an action
distribution of this here.
So north, south, east and west.
So the agent knows that it should go
north.
Why?
Because if I look at the prior preference,
, this state is more preferred than this
state.
Right?
So the agent successfully calculated the
expected free energy and inferred that,
okay, I should go to this state and not
stay in this state.
And because it has the generative model
of transitions available, it can infer
that I should take an action north to go
to this state.
So that's good.
And the agent goes to north.
And at this particular state, the agent
infers that it should go to north
southeast.
So it will take an action east and it
will go here.
And at this point of time, I want your
attention where the action distribution
is equally probable for north and east.
Why is that?
Because the agent is only looking at the
immediate future.
Right.
So let's go back to the prior preference
where the agent is right now here, or is
it here?
Yeah, it is right now here in this
particular state.
And if the agent is considering immediate
consequences of just one action, then
these two states are equally good for it
to be in the next state.
So there is no distinction between these
two states if it is only looking at the
immediate future.
So that means that the expected free
energygies will conclude that I should go
to north or east.
It doesn't matter if I'm looking at just
one time step ahead.
Okay?
That's the idea.
And out of probability it is going here.
It took the action east and from this
state, when it's doing inference, it's
inferring that this state is better and
basically it's ending up in this local
maxima state, which is this particular
state where the neighboring states are
less preferred.
And this is Wall and you can't go there
because it is forbidden for the agent by
structure.
So it's basically going to sit there
forever where it only sees that local
maximum of prior preference.
And let's look at what might happen if
you have higher planning depth.
So if I go to the planning depth of three,
, then that means that the agent is
actually reaching the goal state at the
last time step.
But still in the third time point, it had
two probabilistic actions, north and east.
.
So here from this particular state, out
of probability, it took the action north
but it can all equally take the action
east and end up in this local maxima.
So let's run again and probably it will
end up in this local maxima, okay?
And only for the planning depth of four,
which is sufficient enough, which is
necessary for this particular grid, the
agent is fully sure of what to do.
So at every time point it is fully sure
of what to do, that it has to go north,
then east, north, north, north, east,
east and south and reach this particular
goal state.
So only for time step or planning depth n
equal to four, it can successfully
navigate this grid with 100% certainty.
So that's the idea.
That's the implementation that I hope you
got.
So there is also this idea of action
precision.
So here it's a high action precision.
That is why it is taking the actions.
That is from the probability.
If it is a low action precision like one,
then the good actions are more probable.
But that doesn't mean that it will be
taken right here by luck, it is taking
the right actions and reaching the state.
.
But here probabilities are most passed.
But you will also see like exploration
behavior in more number of trials if you
control this action precision.
So I set it to a high value to make sure
that the agent reaches the goal for this
particular problem.
But it's worth playing and it's important,
, right?
Okay, yeah.
So for different planning depths like one,
, three and four in this problem, this is
the behavior that you expect.
For lower planning depths, which is not
sufficient, the agent ends up in local
maximas or local minimas of expected free
energy or local maximas of prior
preference.
But with sufficient planning depth, it's
able to navigate and reach the goal.
So that brings us to the last point in
this tutorial where why is it important
to have a threshold in evaluating
sophisticated inference?
So by threshold, what we mean is that we
can ignore future possibilities in two
levels, right?
You can ignore not likely actions or not
likely observations in this research.
But if you consider the consequences of
all actions and observations, that means
that you'll have to consider four
consequences in the first place.
Then you will have to consider four times
the action states in the next time step
for the next time step.
Then all of that multiplied with the
number of actions and this tree search
becomes intractable and you'll explode.
And it's even worse than the classical
active inference policy space problem.
But by defining a threshold of even a
small value, we'll ignore possibilities.
So where is that implemented?
In the forward search algorithm, we are
considering actions with only action
probabilities greater than the particular
threshold.
Here I am defining it as one by 16.
Also in the parent paper, it's one by 16
the action probability.
Okay?
So if it is zero, then that means that it
will consider all the consequences of
future and that's intractable.
So you can ignore actions which is not
probable, and also ignore states which is
less likely, or only consider states that
has probability greater than this
particular threshold value, and that
significantly reduces the computational
complexity, where you will only consider
combinations that are probable in the
future.
Tree and that lets you go deeper in your
planning horizon.
That's an important point here.
And if you compare the time that takes
for deeper planning for a search
threshold of zero, so a search threshold
of zero means that you will consider all
consequences.
And the more deep you plan, the more time
it takes.
And if you see to consider only the first
future or the immediate future, it takes
0.1 second.
For considering three possibilities into
the future, it takes 3 seconds, and for
four it takes 300 seconds.
And you can see that the computational
time is exponentially growing.
But if you have a very small search
threshold, you have that computational
time that makes sense for implementation
in real world, right?
So here for N equal to four, that is four
times steps into the future, it's only
taking 0.1 second.
And that's okay.
I can still do simulations with this
complexity, but there is no way I can
talk about how less the computational
complexity is.
It truly depends on the nature of your
prior preferences and environment in
action.
But this search threshold actually works
in real life, and we just saw that in our
simulations, right?
For N equal to four, it took only like 0.
.3 seconds in our simulations.
But if you set the search threshold as
zero, it already is 300 seconds for doing
full depth planning.
And if I set a planning depth of five,
then it will basically run forever maybe,
and I will not be able to do simulation.
So that's the idea of search threshold.
So actually, that's it.
I wanted to explain the Agent class, the
environment class, and the particular
demo and yeah, maybe it's a good time for
questions if anybody was listening.
And I hope people get to play with this
code and look at the tutorial and
implement this and build generative
models like this.
So this particular example is how do you
build a generative model for this grid
world task and see how the Agent is able
to take meaningful actions?
But here we gave it that true structure
of the environment in the B matrix and A
matrix and so on.
But you can also play around with
learning in the sense that while defining
the Agent step, you can add a flag that
says learning equal to true.
And if you start with an uninformed AB
and so on, you can experiment on how the
Agent is learning that environment.
Here you can look at the B matrix in the
beginning, you can look at the B matrix
after, say, ten trials and see how the
learning is taking place here.
It doesn't matter because the agent knows
the structure and it won't learn much.
But if it starts from an unknown
structure, then there is scope of
learning also to be implemented.
And it's already implemented because we
are using existing Pymdp functionalities
for learning A and B and it's already
part of the step function.
So I hope step function is clear, which
is the only thing you need to know if you'
're trying to implement sophisticated
inference and just the names of these
matrices if you want to probe them and
look at them.
And yeah, I hope the session was useful.
So I thank my collaborators and Connor,
who maintains Pimdp, and also Brendan who
runs the Pimdp Fellowship, which I was
part of, and that's where I worked on
implementing sophisticated inference in
Pimdp and it will be part of the original
Pymdp module soon.
And I hope people can start using this
module to simulate sophisticated
inference experiments and this basically
becomes useful.
So maybe it's a good time to discuss
questions or clarifications on the code
or maybe it's a good time to take a break,
, as Daniel was.
Daniel: Thank you.
That was awesome.
Well, I have a few different questions
and I'll read a few from the live chat.
So I'll first just go to the live chat
and then ask those and then ask some
other questions.
So Dave asks, how do you think about the
neural implementation of recursion?
Brains don't seem to implement computer
hardware style recursion deeper than a
stack depth of one.
Aside from heavily over learned tasks, we
can confine ourselves to asking about
recursion for the purposes of exploring
temporally deep state spaces, searching
forward in time.
So how do we reconcile this really
beautiful and elegant and computationally
efficient full depth tree search with the
biological basis of multiscale planning?
Aswin: Yeah, so I'm not an expert in
neural computation, but the answer to
that would be basically you're doing only
one computation at a time, right?
And all you need is some memory to store
your beliefs and use those beliefs to
kind of do the same computation again.
So we are not talking about this hardcore
recursive implementation.
We are only doing local computations at a
time.
And just because of the structure of the
generative model and because we have
memory, this can be done.
And I don't see why brain can't do it,
even though individual neurons might not
be able to do it.
The brain has memory.
The brain has the ability to store memory
and the ability to dream, the ability to
simulate.
It knows the consequences of actions.
And you do this on a daily basis where
you plan your future and decide what to
do.
Right?
So on a single neuron level, I'm not
really sure of how to answer that
question, but I don't really see why the
brain can't do it as an organism.
Cool.
Daniel: Okay, to the code.
I guess I have a few questions.
Can we go back to the maze?
And of course, if anyone else has
questions in the live chat, just go for
it.
So in the maze, how does the moves that
are possible, how is that reflected?
What stage is it updated, for example,
that it initially knows that it can only
go up and then it can only go right or
down?
Where is that reflected with the updating
of kind of that relational aspect of
affordances?
What is even possible to do?
And then how does it evaluate in a deep
tree search?
Does it need to know what things could or
couldn't happen in the future?
Aswin: So, if I understand the questions
correctly, there is an important
distinction between the generative
process and the generative model, right?
So in the grid world, which is the
generative process, we have implemented
all of that manually, where we have this
transition dynamics that already knows
what will happen if you take an action
from a state.
So it's like an environment that knows
how to work.
So it's like a reality where there are
consequences of actions and it's already
there.
But this information is available to the
agent to be part of its generative model.
.
And in the generative model, what it
basically does is use that transition
dynamics, which is given or learned to
simulate what might happen in the future.
.
Okay?
So once I have that transition dynamics,
if I go to the where's the if I go to the
tree search, what it is essentially doing
is evaluating the posterior given a
particular state and an action J.
So from my generative model, I know that
if I start from this state and if I take
this action, I go to this posterior and I
consider all the consequences.
And if in the generative model, it is
unlikely that if I go east, I don't go
there and so on, it's automatically
reflected in the expected free energy.
So I hope that answers the question.
So here, if I set the action precision to
be high and also enable the so initially
I am in this particular state, and with
respect to the expected free energy, what
I'm doing is I'm using my generative
model to predict what will happen if I
take four actions.
And my predictions will say that if I
take North, I will go here.
And if I take all the other actions, I'll
stay here.
And because in my prior preference, north
is more preferred, I can infer that north
is the action I should go for.
So that's the idea.
So here, the grid structure is given to
the agent.
And it might be a little confusing, but
the agent can also learn this grid
structure and this will work.
So once I know the grid structure as an
agent, I can simulate the future and
consider the consequences of action,
right?
So that's what's happening.
And once I am in this state, I will
consider the consequence of all four
actions, and I will infer that, okay,
going east is better because that will
take me to this state.
So there is always a difference between
or you should keep in mind how generative
model and generative process are two
different things, and what the agent
knows might not be the reality or might
be the reality, depending upon what you
give it.
Makes sense.
Cool.
Daniel: So if you were going to go about
making a new situation that you wanted to
do generative modeling for, do you tend
to start from an existing working Pi MDP
notebook and start modifying state spaces,
, or do you draw it out on a canvas?
How would you recommend somebody other
than replicating what is shown here?
Let's just say we're interested in
something that's not exactly just a maze.
.
What do we do to get our head around how
we should proceed?
Aswin: Yeah, good question.
So if you are trying to simulate, say, a
new environment, you have the heavy
lifting to do, which is to define the
generative model for the agent.
You can either define a very sparse
generative model, which the agent can
learn, but you have to define the
structure.
That structure should be there, and only
using that structure, the agent can learn
the generative model.
So here you can make use of this cell of
code to understand how I define the
structure of the grid.
Okay, so I am defining a structure for
the agent for it to make use of.
I'm saying that there are 25 valid states
and there are four available actions.
And this is the standard way of defining
the state space in Pymdp.
And you also have to define the central
parameters ABC and D for the agent
simulations.
So here I am defining A using my state
space and observation space.
But this step of giving it or telling it
that it's an identity matrix is my
decision choice in my modeling.
I don't have to do this for simulations.
I can see if the agent is learning it
from a random A matrix or when it starts
from a random A matrix.
And similarly for this B matrix, this
structure is defined.
And there are functions like this which
can give you a random B matrix.
But this is a modeling choice where if I
want to give it the grid structure or not
give it the grid structure, I can start
from a random B matrix, let the agent
learn, and look at that learned B metric.
.
Just for the purpose of the demo.
I gave it the grid structure to enable it
to take the actions.
But it's not a mandatory thing.
So this notebook is useful in the sense
that you know what to do, but definitely
you should play around with steps that
may not be mandatory.
Right, so if I give a prior preference
for this state to be the maximum, then
you can see behavior that.
The agent will try and go there.
Right.
So this prior preference is defined in
conjunction that this is the goal state,
but this may not be the goal state.
And in a different ask, what prior
preference means is different according
to the environment.
Right.
So that's also there and your prior.
So once you define that generative model,
which you have to do, you can't run from
it, then everything is kind of automated.
.
The agent only have to use the agent step,
, give it the observation from the
environment.
The agent knows how to take actions, and
then everything that happens inside the
agent, you don't really have to worry.
So this structure, I'm sure, will be
useful for your particular task that you
are trying to model in your hmm.
Daniel: Yes, very interesting.
And how would you contrast that or point
to any similarities or differences with
how this would be pursued outside of
active inference?
Like if somebody were just going to use
another kind of deep policy agent in the
maze example, what parts of the process
would be familiar and what parts would be
like a lot of work that wasn't expected
or skipping through parts that were a lot
of work otherwise.
Aswin: Yeah.
So the general structure is very familiar
to somebody who does things like this in
reinforcement learning.
So the idea that it's an agent step and
environment step, so this is the standard
OpenAI gym way of writing an environment
and a standard OpenAI way of writing an
agent.
Okay?
So if you have a Q learning agent who
does the same trying to navigate, then
the way you have to define the queue
matrix is the heavy lifting there.
It's just a state action mapping.
And in contrast to that, in active
inference, you have to come up with a
generative model that you want to see.
So in active inference, generative model
is the central thing.
Right.
Without a generative model, there is no
meaning of purposeful behavior in active
inference.
So the only unfamiliar part for a person
who is coming from, say, a field like
reinforcement learning is the structure
of the generating model.
But there is no way, other than getting
used to it, where it's the palm DP
structure which dominates.
But if you're doing deep active inference,
, all of this is going to be neural
networks and palm DPS are also not active
inference things.
Right.
It's an industrial engineering thing.
So palm DPS must also be familiar for
people who are coming from the computer
science background, just the idea that
what really happens in the agent is the
active inference part where we have
expected free energy s and variation of
free energy energies.
And if you want to learn about that, then
you have to go to the agents and see how
it works.
Look at the matrices numerically, see
what's happening.
But in a level where you want to get
started, I don't see any problem.
All of this is standard frameworks like
palmdps and OpenAI gym environments,
agent environment loop.
All this is very deeply discussed in
computer science.
It's not cool.
Daniel: So what other motifs or cognitive
phenomena are you excited or how do you
see the Pi MDP development trajectory
continuing after your sophisticated
inference gets pulled in?
Aswin: Yeah, so the Pimdp had the
original functionality and the
functionality to implement or simulate
general active inference agents with the
policy space and so on.
And that enabled a lot of people in the
community who are not familiar with
complicated coding and so on, who people
who do psychology, psychiatry, and all
the things.
Right.
So whoever want to come up and try
implement active inference, pymdp enabled
that.
And I am hoping that this module will
enable people who want to try out
sophisticated inference experiments in
their particular domain.
So if you spend some time and get
familiarized yourself with the structure
of how Pymdp works, then everything else
is just writing a jupyter notebook with
minimal code, right, to simulate this.
So if you have a particular task in your
domain, I don't see a problem for a
beginner to kind of try and code it.
And what I'm very excited to see is
people using this module for variety of
experiments, just like how people started
using Pymdp and sophisticated inference
is taking off.
And it's now widely talked about how it
is the way of doing active inference.
And I'm really hoping that people in
various domains start using this module
and see their experiments, and I look
forward for the feedback.
Yeah, so what Pimdp did two years ago, I'
'm hoping this module will do to people
who are trying to model active inference
in the soap state.
Daniel: So you mentioned the OpenAI gym
and the standardized format, and what
benchmarks do you use or what kind of
test suites are you comparing, and how do
we really know when we've made a
generative model that really exceeds or
excels in a way that other techniques are
just not doing?
Aswin: Yeah, so if I may go to the OpenAI
gym website, we have several experiments.
.
There the classical reinforcement
learning examples like the lunar lander
that you see in this screen right now.
So active inference from its inception
has faced problems of scaling to tasks.
And that's in itself a field of research
in active inference, scaling active
inference.
And that's one of the reasons why deep
active inference took over dealing with
tasks like this.
So there are benchmarks even now where
the sophisticated inference may not be
able to deal with state spaces.
And personally, that's my research.
In my PhD.
I am actually looking at optimizing
computations in sophisticated inference
algorithms that lets you scale up to
environments like that.
But to get started, you will have to kind
of write code and see if it works for an
environment, then look at if it's not
working, then you have to look at methods
to scale it up and so on.
So if I am talking about benchmarks,
sophisticated inference is as good as any
RL algorithms for this state space.
So for small problems, sophisticated
inference will work and it's really good.
.
But for high dimensional problems like
this, the classical implementation that I
just showed might not work, but it's good
enough for any decent experiment.
But if you want to scale up, then that's
still open and it's a new field of
research and what you do might become a
next new important paper.
So that's all I can tell in that regard.
Cool.
You have to work and see what.
Daniel: Measures do you think you'd be
looking for, like computational resources
or what are the measures that even make
sense to juxtapose such different
methods?
Aswin: Yeah, so the OpenAI Gym was
designed for that, to compare different
algorithms.
So OpenAI Gym by definition is a
collection of many environments.
So in my demo, I was talking about the
grid environment.
Openiigm is nothing but a collection of
many environments which will let you
interact with those environments using
the environment step function.
Yeah.
So here we have the environment step
function that will let you interact with
the lunar lander.
And that particular task will have
matrixes that lets you judge how good or
bad your algorithm is.
So in this lunar lander problem, how
optimally can you land your rover between
these two flags by spending minimizing
the fuel and so on.
So those matrices are very tasks specific,
, and that's one direction you have to
take.
You can take try and compete with RL
algorithms in matrixes, but the right
potential or the potential I see in
sophisticated inference is modeling
intelligent behavior, where in RL the
focus is to get things done to make this
work.
But it's not really explainable,
especially deep RL and deep learning
methods.
But in active inference, if you manage to
scale it up, they are explainable and
that will let you understand how
intelligence emerges with time.
And I see that more interesting than
competing with RL, because if your focus
is getting things done, then maybe
engineering is the right way and not
active inference.
Awesome.
Daniel: Any other comments or thoughts?
Aswin, do you have any other comments or
thoughts?
Aswin: No, I'm pretty happy.
I hope I was clear explaining the code.
Maybe it was too complicated or simple,
depending upon your level, but I hope it
is useful to at least one person who
would start using this and write the code.
.
Thank you so much for your time.
Awesome.
And thank you for the opportunity.
Daniel: Thank you for joining.
Till next time.
See you.
Aswin: Thank you so much.
Bye.